hi Jackie how are you I'm doing well
babe how are you better than I deserve
what's up so I am looking for
suggestions on how to how to ask for a
salary increase I have been in the first
time I've really been in a corporate job
for about the past five years and while
I've moved up in position and gotten
increases at that point I've been in the
same position now for about three years
and just gotten my annual you know one
and a half two percent raises and I'm
really looking for a larger increase so
I'm looking about how to present that to
my director okay
swap shoes with your director for a
minute you're now sitting on the other
side of the desk and a lady that's
worked on your team for three years with
cost of living raises only comes into
your office and she's gonna ask for a
raise you're leading her she's she's
valuable to your team why would you give
her a raise what would she say to you if
you're sitting there is the director
under what circumstances are you giving
out raises great right
so I initially what I thought I could do
is maybe go over like my portfolio
portfolio of work over what I've done is
maybe in the past year or so and present
to them the additional workloads that
I've taken on as well as the courts of
the department's oversaw the day you're
on the other side of the desk the person
comes in and they're going to show you
their portfolio of work is that what you
want to see is that why you're going to
give them a raise
well yeah I'd like to see that there's
going above and beyond what their normal
work vote is okay good good and I can
tell you as a business owner a business
owner there's two or three reasons I
would give someone
arrays if they came into my office and
asked for it okay number one we are
under paying them accidentally
we just haven't kept them all we just
haven't kept up the position is worth
more than it is being paid and I would
need to see some data points that say
that project managers in Boston
you know PM 2's make X and here's some a
comp study that says the typical person
doing what I do in this area makes what
do you make now as an example I make
okay and so you do a comp study and you
go here's here's three different data
points from compensation studies on the
internet that show the project managers
that do what I do at my level a p.m. 2
p.m. 3 whatever you are you know make
80,000 I'm being paid 70 I you know I
really don't want to leave here I like
this place and I just like to be paid
market value so one reason is is that
I'm not paying market value as the owner
or the director and that's an accidental
thing I didn't intend to under pay and
when you bring it to my attention boom
you've gotten a raise okay that would be
one reason you would get a raise
the second reason you might get a raises
if you show me that you are worth more
because you've added value somehow and
that could be something like the working
extra it could be you brought in some
clients it could be you closed out on
project 3 times earlier than the typical
project manager and you got this thing
done it moved on to the next project I'm
making this company a lot of money and I
can prove it to you and here's the value
that I'm bringing and so you know I'd
like a raise right so generally speaking
in a corporate environment you are paid
what you can be replaced for right and
if they can replace you cheaper than you
are being paid your job might be in
danger right okay and vice versa I agree
and vice versa if that if they can't buy
another person just like you for 80
grand and they're paying you 70 grand
they'll probably up you know get you up
close to 80 just to keep you around
because they're going to go get some
to pay them a tea and that's that was
the first version of that a comp study
so but you did you don't go in with an
entitlement and the number of years I've
been here in the fact that I breathe air
and you owe me money because I'm me and
I'm special and you're not and I'm not
and we just had we're only as special to
in a company setting is the work we get
done that's what that's about that's
what adds value and that's you know that
that's what I'm worth you're on the
radio if I don't do a good job I don't
make my advertisers money I get fired by
one of them right and they leave it'll
give it somebody else their money and
that's just so you have to add value and
and prove it and then that now the only
other thing and sometimes this is
difficult for someone in a corporate
setting to put a value on but I teach
entrepreneurs and small businesses to
put a value on this if you have been
doing this particular job for three or
four years you know the culture you know
how to get things done inside the
politics you know how who to go see and
get pull things off if they hired
someone new into your role
it might take that person several months
maybe even a year to get up to the speed
that you are because you know how to get
stuff done there meaning my personal
assistant has been with me 17 years to
replace patty would be she is worth more
than then a personal assistant would be
that replaced her because of the 15
years of experience and she can read my
mind you know and she knows what's going
right so she is more valuable because of
that experience then than just the
position and I always try to teach young
company owners young businesspeople that
because they think you know I'm just
trying to replace the position and I
would never pay somebody that yeah you
would if they get been doing it ten
years because they bring value to the
table that is beyond what just the new
person coming into that slot would
sometimes it's harder to corporate
America to get people to get a hold of
that so hey thanks for the call